he has a longtime fear of being poisoned
one reason why he liked to eat at
McDonald's
was coming and the
that's it we've got it that's the one
you think so oh yeah the Grammys in the
bag in the back Hillary Clinton was a
big star at the one place she would be a
big star of the hyper politicized Grammy
Awards if you missed the Grammy Awards
you were not alone many people did
ratings fell to record lows last night
it was fitting that Hillary Clinton
would be celebrated by show business
she's got one thing in common with
Hollywood both them appear to have a
sexual harassment problem Patti Solis
Doyle who you may remember managed
Clinton's 2008 presidential campaign not
a staff runner she managed it campaign
manager she said today that she wanted
senior advisor burns Strider fired for
sexual harassment but Hillary wouldn't
have it watch I did my due diligence I
interviewed all the parties involved I
looked at the evidence I looked at some
emails that he had sent I had looked at
other documents and came to the
conclusion that there was sexual
harassment involved that the young woman
was very credible and my recommendation
to the senator with to pirate and I was
overruled
so she overruled you personally I was
overruled yes Wow meanwhile Hillary also
praised women in a video that we're not
going to characterize but instead play
and you can decide for yourself hey
everyone
I just wanted to say thanks thanks for
your feminism for your activism and all
I can hope is you keep up the really
important good work
and let me just say this is directed to
the activist [ __ ] supporting [ __ ]
let's go
mark Stein is on tonight's receive
thanks for his feminism and his activism
he's an author and a columnist and he
joins the same arc hey you took a good
see you what do you make of that video
well that last one I think is kind of
pathetic because it's it's it's like
watching some weird kind of Golden Girls
on Meet the Press where you've got all
old broad all old broads Barry White
doing a rapping granny routine it's kind
of pathetic the kind of old broads
talking dirty thing and it's
particularly it's not just pathetic but
it's actually ridiculous on the day that
Hillary has been exposed yet again not
as a champion of women but as an enabler
of men who prey on women well see that
was the thing it wasn't even the naughty
word that bugged me she's she's got a
salty mouth I kind of like that about
it's like the one thing I like about her
what bothered me was that she describes
herself as a feminist and I'm thinking
well compared to you I'm the feminist
there was some guy in my office was
hassling women in the office eyed cannon
she didn't so how does she get to be a
feminist
well you'd almost get the impression
that if you've turned a blind eye to one
predator for 40 years it becomes very
easy to turn a blind eye to all of them
and in that sense that's what she shares
with those people at the Grammy Awards
that it's a power thing it's a class
thing and it's a power thing and that's
the way it's always been the women that
Bill Clinton hit on whether they were
interns or whether they were low-grade
staffers she regarded them as trash her
advisor said you drag a hundred-dollar
bill through a trailer park there's no
telling what you'll find and that's what
she and guys like Harvey Weinstein are
all agreed on and it's a problem for the
day
at party kirsten gillibrand who is
apparently serious about running for
president was on TV I think was today or
yesterday and she was doing a thing oh
you know believe all women
zero-tolerance or all the rest of it and
then she was asked well wait a minute
what what about a Hillary Clinton oh
because she's still worried that the
Clintons are powerful enough to take the
tire iron to her in the back alley it
would be in the interests of the
Democrat Party for her for them to tell
Hillary Clinton stop doing your
Catskills
ledin Catskills stick on TV every ten
minutes and and go to the Falkland
Islands for the next three years and you
might give us a sporting chance
ledin Catskills stick you know I took 48
years for me to hear that phrase but I'm
so glad it was worth it
TACA politicians should I shouldn't do
comedy and if they do it they should do
it once once every 30 or 40 years
Hillary's doing every show she shouldn't
she should say I'm not gonna do it again
until the year 2050 7 she'd be doing us
all a favor Mark Steyn you've done us a
favor thank you thanks taco